gwen what is up well okay so i'm 36
i'm married i have four boys um
hey hold on hold on hold on
will you do that again for me yeah
and i want you to do it where the end of
your sentence doesn't curtail down but
it curtails up
okay okay so the way i heard that was
i'm 36 i have four boys and i think i
want to set my
hair on fire and i want to hit my own
feet with a sledgehammer
let's do it the other way and then come
out and say i'm 36
i've got let's do it like that okay okay
okay ready go okay
i'm 36 i'm married i have four boys
um i've reached a point in my life where
i just feel like i'm
really struggling um just
with um i guess my expectations
versus my reality yeah i can hear it
even when you said you're gonna be like
all right i'll talk more positive
it went right back down so what's what's
why are you struggling between your
expectations and your reality
so um i'm sorry no
i'm sorry this is hard stuff okay yeah
that's tough um so
my mother suffered with mental illness
and
um like schizophrenia manic depression
bipolar who knows really
okay so hard stuff though um yeah yeah
so i spent you know most of my childhood
with her
and you know i just i promised myself
when i was a little girl that when i was
grown i was going to do
all the things that i needed to do to
you know live a good life and
you know have happy family and do all
the things and i feel like i've done
all the things but it just hasn't
fixed it you know what i mean like i
still feel
broken and i don't want to i don't want
to feel this way anymore
yeah i'm so sorry i feel like it's
starting to overflow into like my
and i don't know why it just feels like
all of a sudden
at this point my life it feels like it's
bothering me more than it ever has
um you know i don't want to be a moody
person or irritable or
yeah short with my husband or my kids or
you know any of the things but i'm here
and i don't know how to get out i don't
know how to get out of this place that
i'm
in yeah have you met with somebody
before
i have not okay it's not something i
really i have ever really talked about i
just
you know just i just haven't
um tell me about your dad
um you know he was a good man he got
custody of my sister and i when i was
11. you know he did the best he could he
was an
alcoholic sort of like you know he drank
a lot but he
kept a good job and did the best he
could
is your mom still alive
as far as i know i have not seen her in
25 years so
i have not you know i have no um
i have no idea really um and i think
that's one of the things that
bothers me a little bit i don't have a
relationship with her i don't want a
relationship with her
sure um and i feel guilty for them
sure um so here's
here's um i'm gonna be as honest with
you as i can
okay okay um
so first when i heard your voice when
you picked up the phone
and i i when you said hi and you started
talking about yourself
my instant feeling when you
curtailed your words down
was that you've had a really gnarly it
was instant
you've got something in your soul that's
been there a long long time a really
gnarly past and
right when you told me that your mom's
got schizophrenia and or bipolar and or
who knows
and you come from a loving yet alcoholic
father
you had two people on planet earth who
were assigned
to let you know that you were loved and
that you were valued and that you were
worth
something and that you were worth
something they showed you that through
their attention
through their boundary setting through
their showing up
and you didn't get that
you didn't get that and i want to tell
you that sucks it's not the way it's
supposed to be
your mom was sick your dad was sick and
he was doing the best he could
but she didn't get that
and so before we go anywhere else i want
you to tell you that you're loved and
i'm sorry that that happened to you
okay thank you
you've got some deep trauma wounds
and you're gonna have to get with a
professional who's gonna walk you back
and you're going to have to it's not
going to be long doesn't have to be for
the rest of your life
but you're going to have to process some
of that stuff because here's the deal
you've spent the last 20 years healing
from that
and my guess is when you grow up no i
know this
but my guess is you've spent the last 25
35 years making sure everyone around you
is okay
making sure everybody around you has
everything that they need
and you've really been trying to chase
peace and
um you've been trying to chase stability
through making sure everyone around you
is okay
in these external things and
that's not where you find peace you find
peace from the inside out
and usually we find peace when we're
tethered to something and you were shot
out of the cannon completely untethered
and it's not your fault
and so i want you to know that you're
loved you're a person of value your
husband loves you your kids love you
but you're gonna have to do some work
from the inside out
okay and i wish there was something on
this radio call that i could say you
need to go do these four things and it's
going to be all right
but it's gonna be hard i also want you
to know this
it's okay to put your mom down to stop
carrying her around with you
okay it's okay to put your dad down
and stop carrying him around with you
okay tell me about your husband
he's a good man yeah he's great he's
he's my rock he's
wonderful great dad do you trust him
yeah absolutely do you trust him with
everything
um i mean absolutely i have no reason
not to
um okay does he tell you that he loves
you never really
oh yeah yeah does he tell you that
you're beautiful
yes does he tell you that you're a good
mom
yes all right i want you to believe him
okay because right now you're listening
to voices
it is because you're listening to voices
that have been talking to you since you
were four years old and five years old
and six years old
and those voices are
take care of dad watch out for mom
everybody be quiet you're not good
enough
and those voices have been in your head
and they've been in your head and
they've been in your head
and i want you to start listening to the
other voice in your head that tells you
you're beautiful
you're a great mom he picked you out of
all the people he could have picked
and that you're awesome
okay okay but i want you to make me a
commitment that before
tomorrow is over you're going to call
somebody in your local area you're going
to call counselor you're going to call
marriage and family therapist
you're going to let them know i've got a
history of some trauma
some history of some mental health
issues with my mom some severe mental
health issues
some addiction with my dad and
i'm ready to do the work now so that i
can become whole from the inside out
okay okay and okay
i want you to call me back in a month or
two after you've had a couple of
sessions
okay and when you call
even if you gotta fake it i want you to
call and say
um my name's gwen
i've got four kids four crazy smelly
weird
hairy boys and i've got a husband that
loves
me okay
okay is that fair yeah
you promise you're gonna call somebody
in the next 24 hours
yes i will do it you're brave gwen
you're brave you're brave
and i want you to know this too gwen
everyone listening to this
just sat back and exhaled a little bit
when you said you would and i want
everyone listening to this
everybody watching this to recognize
gwen's bravery and i want you to know
you're brave too and if you got to make
a call to go sit with somebody
and let them know hey this is what my
childhood was like i need to work
through some stuff so that i can be
present here for myself
present here for my kids present here
for my current husband for my wife
go do it go do it go make that call gwen
you are a rock star
you're awesome trust that guy you
married and then trust the professionals
that you're going to get involved with
good for you